should i stay or should i go now
should i stay or should i go many people
are rethinking overseas trips this fall
as the covet cases skyrocket a recent
trip advisor survey shows that 31
percent of americans plan to travel this
labor day weekend but most are choosing
to leave their passport at home with 86
percent going somewhere in the u.s
travel news directorate conde nast
traveler that's arian florio joins us
now to discuss aaron good morning good
to see you good morning good to see you
so where's everybody going what is it
what are you what does your crystal ball
say well you're not wrong for labor day
most of us are saying domestic uh we're
doing a lot of the trends we've been
seeing throughout the pandemic which is
a lot of road travel a lot of staying
close to home a lot of outdoor trips but
going into the fall you know people
still really do have their eyes on
hopefully international travel so that
14 of people who may be traveling abroad
this weekend and the many more people
who are dreaming of that big overseas
trip uh what advice do you have for them
and the eu doesn't seem to want us yeah
i was going to say yeah the message
seems to be don't come exactly well okay
those are two sort of different
questions and i'll get to both of them
the first i would say if you are going
to travel travel responsibly this is the
message we are putting out across the
board there are ways to do it but you
have to take into account the new
additions to your trip planning that
maybe weren't there pre-covered that
means keeping up to date with the cdc
recommendations they have a very updated
list on the low risk to very high risk
countries check that and make sure
you're planning accordingly
also check local government websites
they have different requirements to
allowing different people in so make
sure you are compliant with the local
government and that destination actually
wants you to do and of course we have
all this information on contents
contentnesstraveler.com cnc.com so you
can keep up to date there as well and
uh with regards to the european union i
know the big news this week was you know
americans are off the safe list but
really what that means is that the eu
has recommended that their member states
put restrictions on american travelers
it's up to those member states to
comply to adopt them
they can choose to do what they want
with them what i personally think that's
going to mean is not necessarily
blocking americans is going to mean
americans are now going to have to show
proof of vaccination as well as a
negative cova test to enter right now
certain member states require the cova
test or the vaccine i think we're going
to see a mix of both there's a
headlight i was going to say you
recommend travel insurance i absolutely
recommend travel insurance we always
recommend travel insurance especially
now during covid um what i would say be
mindful not all travel insurance
policies are the same you really want to
look out for the ones that give you the
cancel for any reason policy which is
you know self-explanatory it really gets
you out of some potentially harmful
situations but on top of travel
insurance there's a couple other things
you can do to really safeguard your trip
you can't control everything but you can
take measures to make it a little bit
more comfortable we really recommend
getting a travel specialist more
commonly called a travel agent
revelation travel agent exactly i like
that travel specialist well you think
it's okay can i call them on the
telephone 80s or 90s term but really i
mean these people i think that's a good
idea they know a lot of stuff yes yes
yeah and if something really bad happens
and you need you know last-minute fix
they will take care of it for you cool i
have one of those i think it's very
important good advice aaron florio you
look great too
brandi and cheryl on the case
the first ever conde nast traveler
global issue is on newsstands right now
we will be right back